[Musik]
konsequenzen aus hanau
die polizei soll moscheen und andere
sensible einrichtungen schützen
weitere details zum mutmaßlichen täter
parlamentswahl mit einschränkungen in
iran hat der religiöse führer khamenei
viele reform kandidaten von den
wahllisten streichen lassen
deutsche doppel erfolg die skispringer
karl geiger und stephan leyhe dominieren
den weltcup in raßloff
die nachrichten des tages heute mit
petra gerster guten abend willkommen bei
den heute -nachrichten die vom sport hat
norbert lehmann für uns dabei einen
guten eindruck von mir
der mörderische rassistische anschlag
von hanau mit elf toten neun davon
menschen mit migrationshintergrund ist
in wenigen monaten schon das dritte
rechtsterroristische attentat nach der
ermordung des kasseler
regierungspräsidenten walter lübke und
dem anschlag auf die synagoge in halle
es zieht sich eine blutspur durch unser
land sagt innenminister seehofer und
kündigt mehr polizeipräsenz in
deutschland an
florian berlin-neukölln die größte
moschee der hauptstadt am freitagmittag
steht ein polizeiwagen vor der tür
man habe nach dem anschlag von hanau die
schutzmaßnahmen angepasst heißt es von
der berliner polizei
solche maßnahmen würde es ab sofort
deutschlandweit geben kündigt der
bundesinnenminister am vormittag an die
gefährdungslage durch rechtsextremismus
antisemitismus und rassismus ist in
deutschland sehr hoch
wir werden die polizeipräsenz in ganz
deutschland erhöhen
mehr polizei vor moscheen an flughäfen
bahnhöfen oder beim karneval
es ist ein reflex nach einem anschlag
wie in hanau einen anderen verkneifen
sich die minister heute zunächst den ruf
nach neuen gesetzen gestern erst war ein
schärferes waffenrecht in kraft getreten
wer einen waffenschein will wird nun
automatisch vom verfassungsschutz
überprüft und deswegen geht es jetzt
nicht darum gesetze zu verschärfen
sondern wir werden genau hinschauen
müssen ob die gesetze die in kraft sind
ob die auch entsprechend ausgeführt
werden der generalbundesanwalt bestätigt
unterdessen dass der mutmaßliche täter
bereits im november bei seiner behörde
eine strafanzeige gegen ein geheimdienst
gestellt habe was in der strafanzeige
aber nicht enthalten war
waren diese rassistischen ausführungen
zur vernichtung bestimmter volksgruppen
wenig später sitzen an selber stelle
vertreter der muslime und beklagen die
alltägliche islamfeindlichkeit werde von
der politik verharmlost weiterhin
haben wir jedes jahr zwischen 50 bis 100
übergriffe nur auf moscheen
mehrere hundert übergriffe auf
muslimische menschen das schweigen geht
weiter wie lange moscheen nun stärker
bewacht werden
das konnte der innenminister heute nicht
sagen in hanau ist die erschütterung
besonders groß viele menschen gedenken
der toten aus ihren reihen versammeln
sich auf dem marktplatz halten sich an
den händen
sie zeigen solidarität mit den muslimen
die sich zunehmend unsicher fühlen in
diesem land andrea meuser aus hanau am
zweiten tag nach dem anschlag
fotos und kerzen
politische plakate und blumen so zeigen
die hanauer ihr mitgefühl
am späten nachmittag dann eine
kundgebung von freunden und familien der
opfer sie sprechen von trauer und wut
aber auch von angst in ihrer stadt
ich finde ich die nächste wahl ich
schwarze haare habe meine mutter fragt
sich was passiert mit meinen kindern
wenn sie morgen auf die straße gehen wir
fragen uns alle was passiert in diesem
land im vorfeld waren vater und bruder
eines der getöteten in den kurdischen
verein der stadt gekommen
auch sie voll schmerz und gleichzeitig
dankbar für den gestrigen besuch des
bundespräsidenten
das war auch nicht selbstverständlich
dass eine präsident zu sein allerdings
kommen deswegen sind wir noch extra
dankbar dafür dass er sich die mühe
gemacht hat und hier hergekommen ist
auch ne auch in der moschee der
ahmadiyya-gemeinde besonnene töne aber
auch die forderung nach einer reaktion
der politik
die bluttat von hanno wohl kein anschlag
im affekt bilder einer
überwachungskamera zeigen dass tobias er
zumindest einen der tatorte im vorfeld
ausspähte zwei waffen wurden
sichergestellt für beide hatte er eine
waffenbesitzkarte
der vater des attentäters überlebte den
amoklauf seines sohnes er wird als zeuge
verhört
die ereignisse und entwicklungen in
hanau können sie bei uns jederzeit
online verfolgen und zwar in echtzeit in
form eines live blogs auf heute.de der
anschlag von hanau hat auch auswirkungen
auf den bürgerschaftswahlkampf in
hamburg zwei tage vor dem urnengang
verzichten die parteien auf
abschlusskundgebungen gemeinsames
gedenken der wahlkämpfer gestern vor dem
rathaus
nach dem zdf-politbarometer kommen die
sozialdemokraten auf 39 prozent die cdu
auf 12 die grünen 24 prozent die linke 8
einhalb die fdp 5 prozent die fdp käme
auf 6 prozent
nach thüringen und zu der frage wie es
mit der regierungskrise dort weitergehen
soll
rot rot grün und die cdu suchen auch
heute wieder nach einer lösung
jetzt heißt es dass einige
cdu-abgeordnete doch für den linken bodo
ramelow stimmen könnten und ihm damit
eine mehrheit bei der wahl zum
ministerpräsidenten verschaffen
da fragen wir nach bei melanie haack in
erfurt was hören sie über die
verhandlungen
ja dazu dass die cdu bodo ramelow die
stimmen verschaffen könnte dazu dringt
noch nichts nach außen hier aus dem raum
hinter uns in dem jahr seit heute mittag
getagt wird voll knapp zwei stunden dann
hat sich die cdu zurückgezogen
sie ist noch nicht zurückgekommen es
heißt aber man habe sich auf mehrere
punkte einigen können unter anderem auf
einen sogenannten stabilitätspakt oder
ein stabilitäts verfahren was bedeutet
man wolle sich zu sichern bei künftigen
entscheidungen zusammen die mehrheit zu
erreichen mit cdu linken spd und grünen
um eben nicht auf die stimmen der fdp
angewiesen zu sein
das würde natürlich auch eine kraftvolle
anstrengung bedeuten diese
regierungsarbeit durchzuziehen
der letzte große knackpunkt so hören wir
hier aus verhandlungskreisen sei wohl
der anschließende termin einer möglichen
neuwahl
darüber wird hier noch diskutiert um 20
uhr soll hier eigentlich die
entscheidung kommen
ob sie es bis dahin schaffen wir warten
ab sie halten wir uns die stellung dort
vielen dank melanie haack us-autobauer
tesla darf in brandenburg 91 hektar wald
roden
obwohl die baugenehmigung für seine
autofabrik noch aussteht das zuständige
oberverwaltungsgericht hat eilanträge
von umweltverbänden abgewiesen
tesla erfülle alle voraussetzungen so
das gericht
ab kommendem jahr will der autobauer in
grünheide produzieren langfristig bis zu
500.000 autos jährlich
das corona virus breitet sich weiter aus
israel iran und der libanon melden jetzt
erste infektion in stuttgart ist am
mittag eine bundeswehrmaschine mit
rückkehrern aus der vom virus besonders
betroffenen chinesischen provinz hubei
gelandet die 15 deutschen wurden noch am
flughafen untersucht sie müssen zwei
wochen in quarantäne bleiben
nach brüssel dort wird zurzeit über den
haushalt bis 2027 gerungen
die briten sind nicht mehr dabei und
damit fehlen viele milliarden im budget
bisher zahlte jedes mitgliedsland ein
prozent seiner wirtschaftsleistung in
den eu-haushalt ein um den künftigen
beitrag wird zur stunde noch verhandelt
aber es zeichnet sich offenbar eine
annäherung ab frage an anne gellinek in
brüssel annäherung klingt ja ganz
optimistisch heute morgen saß obwohl er
nach stillstand aus oder
ja das stimmt aber nach 30 stunden
verhandlungen die dieser gipfel jetzt
schon dauert gibt es so eine art kleine
bewegung und das seit sich die deutsche
kanzlerin merkel und der französische
präsident marco aktiv in die
verhandlungen eingeschaltet haben sie
haben einen neuen vorschlag vorgelegt
den sie versuchen sowohl mit den
sparsamen vier nord europäern als auch
mit den freunden der eu fördergelder in
süd und osteuropa zu besprechen
dieser prozess dauert im moment noch an
aber fakt ist dass sich das
gesamtvolumen des europäischen
haushaltes für die nächsten sieben jahre
wohl nach unten bewegt in richtung der
sparsamen und das heißt dass bei den
ausgaben die die europäische union
tätigen will klimaschutz digitalisierung
ein neues loch entsteht von 20 bis 30
milliarden
das heißt dass die eu-27 jetzt
entscheiden muss wo sie denn kürzen will
bei der landwirtschaft dagegen ist
frankreich bei den rabatten dem haushalt
dagegen ist deutschland bei der
regionalförderung das wollen die süd-
und osteuropa nicht also es gibt für den
zweiten abend dieses eu-gipfels zwei
szenarien das eine ist dass die 27
gleich nochmal dem plenum zusammen
kommen sagen wir haben uns angenähert
aber wir brauchen noch mehr zeit um die
ausgaben zu verteilen und deshalb
brauchen wir einen zweiten eu gipfel in
vielleicht zwei wochen oder aber die
gespräche laufen so dass es in die
zweite nacht geht und sie sich
vielleicht doch heute nacht einigen
vielen dank für diese vorläufigen
informationen anne gellinek in brüssel
die iraner wählen heute ein neues
parlament
viele mit wut im bauch und viele gehen
gar nicht erst zur wahl
wenn im land brodelt es nicht erst seit
den protesten gegen die erhöhung der
benzinpreise im november iran steckt in
einer schweren wirtschaftskrise entgegen
den versprechungen des moderaten
präsidenten salih auch die öffnung zum
westen hat nicht geklappt das atom
abkommen ist geplatzt und so könnten vom
allgemeinen frust jetzt die
konservativen hardliner profitieren
jörg brase aus tieren wie viele werden
es am ende sein die heute tatsächlich
zur wahl ohne gingen vielleicht noch
nicht mal die hälfte
ein volk ist müde und frustriert und
soll doch dem feind den usa die rote
karte zeigen so jedenfalls beschwor
irans staatsoberhaupt ayatollah khamenei
die 59 millionen wahlberechtigten zu
wählen ist eine religiöse pflicht die
wahlen garantieren unser nationales
interesse und jeder dem unser nationales
interesse am herzen liegt muss an dieser
wahl teilnehmen doch warum ein parlament
wählen das eh nicht viel zu sagen hat
egal was die 290 abgeordneten
beschließen das letzte wort hat
religionsführer khamenei
da blieben heute viele einfach zu hause
wenn man nur die wahl hat zwischen
schlecht und noch schlechter geht man am
besten gar nicht hin ich habe jedes
vertrauen in das regime verloren nein
ich wähle nicht meine mutter hier wird
auch nicht und mein vater übrigens auch
nicht keiner von uns geht wählen denn
auch die auswahl unter den kandidaten
ist nur begrenzt tausende gemäßigte
bewerber waren im vorfeld vom
islamischen wächterrat nicht zur wahl
zugelassen worden
so ist zu erwarten dass die reformer im
parlament ihre mehrheit verlieren und
die hardliner auch hier die oberhand
gewinnen werden
damit wird es wohl noch weniger
kritische stimmen im parlament geben als
bisher schon erste ergebnisse werden
frühestens für sonntag
freitag ist dem montag auch in hamburg
wieder folgten tausende überwiegend
junge leute dem aufruf von credits for
future mit dabei die schwedische
aktivisten gerät achim berg nach angaben
der polizei forderten rund 20.000
menschen ein zeichen für mehr ehrgeiz
beim klimaschutz
der neue senat müsse entschlossene
handeln im kampf gegen die erderwärmung
es ist wieder berlinale in berlin
gestern abend wurde das größte
publikumsfestival unter den
filmfestspielen weltweit eröffnet 18
internationale filme konkurrieren um den
goldenen bären
heute hat johnny depp seinen neuen film
minamata vorgestellt er läuft nicht im
wettbewerb sondern in der reihe
berlinale spezial nadia nasa mit den
filmischen einzelheiten erst nach berlin
gekommen um ein herzensprojekt
vorzustellen
auf der berlinale präsentiert hollywood
star johnny depp seinen film minamata
über die machenschaften der japanischen
chemieindustrie die im küstenort
minamata jahrzehntelang menschen
wissentlich mit quecksilber vergiftet
und er erzählt die geschichte des
amerikanischen fotojournalisten eugene
smith gespielt von johnny depp der 1971
das leid und den protest dieser menschen
mit seiner kamera festhält und an die
weltöffentlichkeit bringt immer
unterstützt von seiner späteren ehefrau
aline die johnny depp auch mit zur
berlinale gebracht hat die arbeit die
jüdin und seine frau aline in minamata
gemacht haben ist monumental
es war ein harter kampf der für beide
immer wieder auch sehr gefährlich wurde
aber sie haben sich für diese menschen
mit hingebung eingesetzt minamata war
unser letztes gemeinsames projekt vor
dem tod meines mannes aber durch seine
fotografien bleibt er lebendig es sind
bilder wie diese die um die welt gehen
und helfen den skandal aufzudecken
eugene smith und seine frau leben mehr
als zwei jahre mit den opfern der um
katastrophe in minamata den horror denn
diese menschen durchmachen mussten nun
immer noch durchmachen diesen horror
muss man beleuchten überall
deshalb sei es sein wichtigster film
sagt johnny depp noch am späteren abend
feierte auf der berlinale weltpremiere
[Applaus]
und nun zu dir
norbert und zum doppelerfolg der
deutschen skispringer staffelei zweiter
und karl geiger der gewinnt auch das
dritte weltcup springen der saison von
der normalschanze im rumänischen raßloff
der erste deutsche doppel erfolg seit
dezember 2017 als stephan leyhe die eins
aufleuchten sieht ist klar ein deutscher
gewesen weltcup und stefan kraft aus
österreich es knapp geschlagen
in den rumänischen karpaten zeigt leider
dass er seine tolle form
seit seinem ersten weltcup sieg in
willingen halten konnte und geiger
beweis dass in die kleinen schanzen
besonders liegen die außergewöhnliche
sprungkraft des obersten führers kommt
hier am besten zur geltung
nach 100 metern im ersten auch im
finaldurchgang wieder 100 meter sein
fünfter weltcup-erfolg ein überlegener
der kampf um den gesamtweltcup wieder
spannend geiger ist jetzt bis auf 98
punkte dran am führenden österreicher
kraft
auftakt der bob wm in altenberg drei
deutsche damen doppel auf den plätzen
zwei bis vier
junioren weltmeisterin kim ki und
anschieberin kira lipperheide liegen
nach zwei rennen ganz überraschend auf
platz zwei es führt die us top favoritin
kaillie humphries morgen die
entscheidung
die fußball welt setzt nach den morden
von hanau zeichen gegen rassismus wie
etwa bvb kapitän und nationalspieler
marco reus kein tor kein sieg kein titel
im fußball bedeutet mir so viel wie eine
offene und friedliche gesellschaft ich
wünsche mir eine tolerantere welt in der
kein platz für rassismus hass und
fremdenfeindlichkeit ist ja und auch in
der europa league gestern am gedenken an
die opfer von hanau frankfurt als auch
salzburg setzten schweigen zeichen dem
einige unbelehrbare widersprachen
störenfriede riefen der großteil der
menge antwortete passend mit nazis raus
nein zu rassismus und gewalt
sportlich hingegen lief es für die
eintracht optimal der japaner kamera der
gefeierte mann
seine drei tore grundstein für den 4 2
1-hinspielerfolg gegen rb salzburg
und in leverkusen auch da gedachte man
den opfern sprach sich gegen jedwede
form von gewalt aus nachdem bayer gegen
porto bereits mit 2 0 führte gelang den
gästen noch der anschlusstreffer
das auswärtstor macht die aufgabe jetzt
deutlich schwerer
nächste woche dann die rückspiele ja
doch wolfsburg hat gestern an das
hinspiel in der europa league geborene
zu hause 2 1 gegen bei mir danke norbert
das wetter legt am wochenende einen
stürmischen auftritt hin
ab der nacht nimmt der wind an
heftigkeit zu mehr dazu gleich von
besten terry das war es von uns nächste
nachrichten gibt es erst wieder nach
mainz bleibt mainz gegen mitternacht
danke für ihr interesse
warum sehen wir uns wieder wenn sie
mögen bis dahin tschüss
[Musik]
einen schönen guten abend und herzlich
willkommen zum wetter die ruhe vor dem
sturm herrscht derzeit noch denn das
nächste sturmtief steht an
unter das zieht von nordwesten langsam
ins landesinnere und es bringt auch
regen hiermit sie sehen es mit dem
blauen flächen ganz im süden wird es
aber trocken bleiben in der nacht geht
es schon los mit dem sturm an der
nordsee und es kommt auch regen auf nach
süden hin ist es trocken und es klart
auf und bei aufklaren geht es runter mit
den temperaturen bis minus vier grad an
den alpen deutlich milder im norden
frostfrei mit teilweise bis zu acht grad
morgen im tagesverlauf ist viel los
seien sie auf der hut an den küsten gibt
es orkanböen und in den bergen ansonsten
sturmböen verbreitet ja auch dazu
kräftiger regen im süden ist es deutlich
ruhiger mit sonnenschein teilweise höher
bei temperaturen von neun grad an der
küste und 17 grad im süden somit wird es
dort die nächsten tage am sonntag gibt
es einen schweren sturm der einmal quer
über deutschland hinweg zieht und viel
regen mitbringt werte bis 18 grad großen
montag ist es ähnlich mit aber bei
weitem nicht mehr so windig damit ein
schöner abend